cette année alexis de tocqueville s'est
invitée à la fête du droit au tribunal
de versailles il y à presque 200 ans ce
célèbre philosophe et homme politique du
19e siècle connu pour ses écrits sur la
démocratie avait exercé en ces lieux
tocqueville à exercer dans ce tribunal
au début de sa carrière dans les années
10 827 en 1832 comme auditeur de justice
c'est à dire comme juge d'agir l'idée
c'est un peu comme on à la fête de la
science et bien cette affaire connexe le
droit aux usages et aux non juristes
pour cette nouvelle édition l'université
de versailles saint quentin en yvelines
a décidé de mettre à l'honneur la
question de la démocratie
professionnels du droit et étudiants ont
pu confronter leur avis à travers des
lectures des conférences et des débats
je crois que le plus important de ce que
nous y tocqueville sur ce qui se passe
dans le monde contemporain c'est qu'ils
nous mettent en garde contre les dangers
d'une tyrannie de la majorité ma
déclamation portent essentiellement sur
la nécessité de contre-pouvoir efficace
dans une démocratie et les fragiliser
pour deux raisons la première c'est que
on traverse un climat de crise avec un
contexte est difficile et la deuxième
chose c'est qu'il ya un climat de
défiance envers les représentants
ouvert à tous la ligue du droit à
plusieurs objectifs c'est montrer à nos
citoyens concitoyens l'importance du
droit dans la régulation de la société
ce qu'on peut en attendre en termes de
droits mais aussi des devoirs ce que
nous cherchons à faire ici à la faculté
de droit et à travers ce type
d'événement c'est bien sûr de montrer à
nos étudiants qu'il faut absolument
continuer de s'ouvrir sur le monde
actuel sur l'histoire le rendez vous est
déjà pris en 2022 pour célébrer les
soixante quatre ans de la constitution
de la vème république
nouvelle occasion de rappeler au plus
grand nombre que le droit aussi a droit
à sa soirée